we have a wonderful gathering of people
in this room and some in the overflow
room I think we should begin I'd like to
wish to begin with I'd like to wish
everyone a happy new year I wish that to
our students to our faculty and our
guests and to welcome you all to the
first event of the spring 2012 term
tonight's speaker is douglas durst the
edward p bass fellow in architecture the
bass fellowship was made possible by a
generous gift of endowment from ed bass
in 1968 graduate of Yale College and a
member of the class of 1972 in the
school of architecture as senior fellow
of the Yale Corporation at bass plays an
important role in the governance of the
University a very important role his
counsel is especially valuable as the
university addresses stewardship
responsibilities for its extraordinary
collection of architecture while
simultaneously moving forward with new
buildings since his graduation from Yale
ed bass has concentrated his
professional life on to pre-eminently
important issues environmentalism and
urbanism his work as an environmentalist
extends from his founding of the
biosphere experiment at oracle arizona
in 1991 to his catalyzing role in the
transformation of Yale School of
Forestry and environmental studies
turning it into a preeminent force in
research and advocacy as a developer mr.
basses sundance square was responsible
for the revitalization of the once
moribund core of Fort Worth Texas
transforming it into a collection or
tremendous rather transforming a
collection of derelict historic
buildings into a lively entertainment
destination and subsequently adding and
attracting new construction including
skyscraping office towers barge scale
apartment houses and important cultural
facilities the bass fellowship enables
the school to pair a leading developer
with resident or visiting faculty
offering an advanced to do so
fairings make possible within the school
the kind of interchange between
sophisticated architects and
sophisticated market based clients that
characterizes much of the best work
being done in the field today this
interdisciplinary approach between
designer and developer parallels other
efforts we are making actively to bring
together in our studios the diverse
strands of modern life that constitute
the bedrock of contemporary building
practice in addition to property
developers of studios also include
landscape architects engineers and
environmentalists who work closely with
faculty and students design faculty and
students Gerald Hines was the first vast
fellow in 2005 teaching alongside Stefan
banish vas studios have United the
developer is a Stuart Lipton of london
with richard rodgers and chris wise
Roger Madeleine chief executive of
argent a london-based property
development company with Dimitri
Porphyrius and George night Nick Johnson
of Urban Splash from Manchester England
with the london-based firm fat Charles
Atwood of Harrah's the landscape the LAS
vegas-based gaming and entertainment
company with Washington DC architect
David Schwartz Katherine Farley senior
managing director of Tishman Speyer with
Debra Burke and last year Vincent low
Hong Kong with Paul Katz Jamie von
klemperer and forth Bagley of the firm k
PF each of the bath studios has been
documented in a publication beginning
with poetry property in place published
in 2006 and most recently urban
interventions as El Pollo documenting
the Farley perks to do this terms bass
professor is Douglas Durst he is teamed
with bark be Archie ingles founder and
Thomas Christopherson partner in the
Copenhagen and new york-based firm big
we welcome be aki and thomas and look
forward to a great studio we welcome as
well Douglas Durst who is one of New
York's most environmentally sensitive
developers
maybe New York's only environmentally
sensitive developer a third generation
of his family to read the Durst
organization he assumed the role of
president in 1992 a position he is held
in too he held until 2010 when he became
the company's chairman mr. Durst was
born in New York City and is a 1966
graduate of the University of California
at Berkeley returning to New York he
completed two years in the Urban Studies
program at New York University before
joining the Durst organization learning
the business from his father Seymour and
his two uncles Roy and David a director
of The Real Estate Board of New York the
graduate center of the city of
university foundation the new school the
Trust for Public Land and project for
public spaces he is also the co-chair
friends of the Hudson River Park mr.
Durst has been involved with the
theatrical arts as well as environmental
issues for many years and as a member of
the board of directors of the roundabout
theatre primary stages and the town hall
he is in his own personal life a notable
environmental activist having created
the largest organic farm in New York
State recognized as a world leader in
the development of high performance and
environmentally advanced commercial and
residential property the Durst
organization was founded in nineteen
fifteen by Joseph jurist the owner
manager and builder of 13 million square
feet of premier Manhattan office towers
and 2 million square feet of residential
properties it recently finished the in
most environmentally advanced skyscraper
in the United States the 2.1 million
square foot LEED Platinum bank of
america tower at one bryant park
formerly known as 42nd Street in 6th
Avenue
in May 2011 the Durst organization
closed a joint venture agreement with
the port authority of new york and new
jersey for an equity interest in one
world trade center that will make if the
managing partner of the three million
square foot tower with responsibility
for tenant leasing tenant fit-out and
ongoing property management I know you
joined me and looking forward to
tonight's lecture which will be followed
by a reception in the architecture
gallery where where you are all invited
to meet our speaker / refreshments and
to enjoy the exhibition gwathmey seagull
inspiration and transformation now
please welcome douglas durst eighth
Edward B vast visiting professor
delivered the lecture sustainable
development and the Durst organization
Thank You Dean Stern for inviting me and
thank you all for attending in stern
gave most of my speech but I'm going to
go ahead anyway occasionally I am asked
the secret to my success most people
assume that my secret is I did an
excellent job in choosing my parents
indeed an article in Business Week
magazine described me as having been
born on third base spending my youth
trying to steal second today i hope to
explain what has made the Durst
organization successful while being an
innovator and a leader in green design
and I can assure you that it takes much
more than being born into it I guide my
family's business by ensuring that
there's an alignment of interest in
building the best we can and keeping our
buildings that way through hard work
tenacity perseverance listening and
paying attention timing and treating
others as you would like to be treated I
have to admit that a little luck always
helps many members of the family decided
they would rather pursue other careers
and work in the very high pressured and
atmosphere that is in New York City real
estate business but luckily in each
generation some have been able to seize
the trend this opportunity handed to us
and improve it for the next I always
point out that working for the next
generation is the basis of environmental
responsibility we and my family have
been taught since childhood to leave a
place better than we found it my
grandfather Joseph Durst arrived in New
York in 1902 from what was the
austro-hungarian Empire and is now
Poland he was 20 years old a tailor by
training and sodas life savings of three
dollars into the lapel of his coat he
joined his older sister Kyla and began
working as a peddler of clothing on
Manhattan's Lower East Side in 1905 he
accumulated the resources necessary to
start a children's clothing business
with a partner Hyman Rubin this is a
copy of their partnership agreement it's
a page and a half for comparison's sake
here's our joint venture agreement with
the Port Authority for one world trade
center from the meager beginnings of
investing eight hundred dollars in 1905
between both partners seven years later
durston Reuben wrote checks for over one
hundred thousand dollars during Joseph
business and manufacturing and selling
children's clothing he was often asked
advice about real estate and he soon
realized that he could do better in real
estate in 1907 Joseph married rose Reed
Wald they moved to Mount Vernon began
having children and prospered my
grandparents were so well liked and
respected man Vernon that there's still
the street place still a street called
Durst place this is their Mount Vernon
home by 1915 Joseph's partnership with
Rudin Rubin had ended Joseph bought his
first building one West thirty-fourth
Street and the Durst organization was
born my grandfather was an innovator and
a risk-taker he left his homeland for
America started business three years
after he arrived and then jumped into
real estate based on what he'd learned
in the schemata business to succeed in
real estate you must be willing to take
risks but these must be calculated risks
risks based on study and diligence most
builders build the same building over
and over because there's less risk we
always try to build a better building
than our last but we spend time and
money investigating improved methods
we're not always successful but if you
do not make mistakes you can never learn
the very first project I was involved in
with my high school friend Eli Sabra was
a dismal failure but I learned more from
that than I could in any other way from
that disaster Eli decided to stay in
with the food business became a greater
success on his own and I put the lessons
I had learned in
my own family business from 1915 until
nineteen forty-five Joseph Durst bought
sold and traded parcels in South midtown
Manhattan acquiring business acumen
relationships and a keen understanding
of New York real estate he also became a
prodigious philanthropist and a leader
in New York's Jewish community here you
see him with Mayor LaGuardia engaging
the camera in a very postmodern way in
1943 my grandfather purchased 205 East
42nd Street a loft building which had
been built in 1927 which was being used
more for office space at the time
shortly thereafter my father's Seymour
and my uncle's Roy and David joined him
in the business they started thinking
about New York real estate in a
completely new way we still own and
operate this class a office building but
we've rebuilt it four times soon after
acquiring 205 East 42nd Street my uncle
Roy wanted to install a new technology
into the building air conditioning he
asked a few brokers what they thought of
the idea and was told it was just a
waste of money because when it gets hot
everybody goes home
in the early 1950s my father see more of
my uncles Roy and David began taking a
more active role in the business they
work side by side but in three distinct
functions development construction and
management recognizing that the
demolition of the elevated train would
transform third Avenue from bars and
flop houses into Manhattan's next
commercial corridor the organization
began aggressively assembling and then
selling development sites to the other
real estate families my family assembled
the sites of almost every office
building from thirty eighth Street 250
first street on the east side of third
Avenue in 1955 my uncle's father and
uncles decided that they were no longer
being paid a fair price for the sandwich
decided they could build as well as the
others just cause the head of one of the
other real estate families to call my
grandfather and ask Joe do you know what
your sons are doing to which he replied
of course and is their decision this
began the tradition of plans succession
in our family indeed 2009 I stepped down
as president to begin our transition and
I also wanted the opportunity to say I
was retiring so I could spend less time
with my family
but our work at one world trade center
has somewhat delayed this transition in
1958 my grandfather father and uncles
finished our first office building at
655 third Avenue and I was just
mentioning to Dean stern that Paul
Rudolph had his last office in that
building in a penthouse between 1950 8
1969 my family built office towers at
675 733 757 and 825 third Avenue 757 is
the only one we no longer own but all
were designed by Emory Roth and sons
from Richard and Emery Roth we learned
the importance of the inside of a
building and in particular the
efficiency of the core the end of the
60s my father and uncles realized that
midtown Manhattan was once again
expanding and that sixth Avenue was the
next frontier in 1969 we opened 1133
Avenue the Americas another Roth
building and began assembling sites
along sixth Avenue in and around Times
Square it was at this time I made my
first solo foray into Manhattan real
estate after looking at a number of
buildings in Soho I surmised despite the
rock-bottom price that no one would ever
want to live in such an industrial area
and instead partnered with my high
school buddy Eli's a bar on a renovation
at West 78th street it flopped we were
about five years too early we did
however when an aia award for the
renovation excuse me well the city's
fiscal crisis and the national recession
slowed the organization down in the
1970s we opened 1155 sixth avenue in
1984 white case as our anchor tenant
this was the last building we built with
the Roth office had nothing to do people
calling at the dorothy
building white in case recently renewed
and will be a tenant of ours for at
least 35 years one of our tenants
started in 1958 with us 655 third Avenue
with 5,000 square feet and they now have
30,000 square feet at 11 33 sixth Avenue
we form long lasting relationships with
our tenants because we realize we are a
service business our management
philosophy is good service at a good
price we make our money from from rent
from the deal we strike in the beginning
not by overcharging traditional services
because our tenants are captive during
the term of their lease 1982 my cousin
Jodie joined the company and we began to
take a more active role in the
management in 1989 we completed the US
Trust Company building at 114 West
forty-seventh Street designed by Fox and
fell in 1992 I succeeded my father as
president to the Durst organization it
was during this period that Jodie and I
began integrating our family's strong
commitment to the environment into our
buildings all members of my generation
were taught by our grandparents to leave
places better than we found it and we
adopted this as our company's unofficial
model into the design and operation of
our buildings while the company always
made its mark as innovators and
development and design and operation of
our buildings my cousin and I began to
explore sustainability's in buildings in
the early 90s began a process of
retrofitting our buildings with energy
energy efficient lighting unless entered
environmentally damaging HVAC systems in
1993 we had the opportunity to rebuild
1133 Sixth Avenue a major office
building of nine hundred thousand square
feet not an opportunity we sought
because unfortunately the economy was in
a deep real estate recession but with
all the major tenants having expiring
leases and the need to do an extensive
expressed disappointment we could either
abandon the building or rebuild it and
hope to rent it
took us a little to convince the senior
generation but Jodi and I were able to
take this opportunity and the risk of
investing a hundred million dollars into
a vacant building and to build in energy
conserving systems within the building
we installed some of the first variable
frequency drives on our buildings pumps
and motors and put an energy
conservation measures throughout our
buildings all have the same color coded
the mechanical systems so that anybody
can go into any building of ours and
know exactly what is going through the
pipes this relatively modest change
these relatively modest changes with the
beginning of an iterative process that
continues today to build better more
efficient healthier and more sustainable
buildings by 1994 we had renovated at
least 11 33 and I with too much time on
my hands was trying to convince new york
city officials to start the stalled
Times Square redevelopment project i
went from official to official with my
reasons why now is the time for the 42nd
Street project to be building an office
tower in Times Square finally I ended up
in the office of then City Council
Speaker Peter Vallone at that time the
city council had none of its present-day
authority as a matter of fact it had
almost no authority and still Peter only
half listened to me while he kept an eye
on the council proceedings on a TV
finally he turned to me and said what is
it to you if it ever gets developed I
had no answer that night I could not
sleep while Peter's question replayed in
my mind around midnight the answer
suddenly occurred to me we could offer
to build the buildings I reasoned if we
offered to build they would have to pay
attention I woke up my cousins and other
members of the team and told them my
solution of course they thought this
might be a little difficult since we had
spent the past where we spent three
years suing to stop the project and the
developers and state blamed us for the
delays
my cousin told me if I took an aspirin
and went to sleep I would feel better in
the morning but we persevered and
convinced the city state and prudential
who controlled the site that we were
serious and because we were so familiar
with the site from our litigation we
were able to create a plan it's true
they created a plan that was so
complicated that we were the only ones
who really understood it now we're able
to create a plan that made sense for
everyone once given the green light we
assemble the team of oxen valve and
tissue and construction we all agreed
that we would now build the first
high-rise green office building none of
us knew exactly what that meant and so
at the urging of bob fox we staged a
series of off-site retreats to define
what a green building is and although i
prefer the term environmentally
responsible it doesn't quite roll off
the tongue at the retreat we included
the architects engineers building
operations personnel project manager
construction manager as well as
representatives from birthday New York
rocky mountain institute and NRDC we
spent several weeks in all day meetings
and after dinner and drinks let loose
ideas that we'd previously kept to
ourselves and by the end we had a
blueprint for moving forward reform
committees to investigate different
issues create a meeting scheduled and
most importantly got everyone to buy
into the project until projects goal of
building the best building we could in
the past the project I worked on had
meetings that were spent in the blame
game for hours we would we would spend
time while the architect would prove it
was a contractor's fault that something
was delayed or went wrong
and the next week it was the vice versa
and solutions were never found just who
is responsible for what was going wrong
now we do not look for blame only
solutions in the past meetings were
reserved for discussing problems now
problems are addressed before the
meetings and solutions are recommended
at the approved at meetings this
practice is an important part of making
the design and construction process
efficient and efficiency is the heart of
green buildings we not only designed a
fantastic building but created a model
for designing buildings that we follow
for every project where x square is a
great building its architect Leda sting
guished energy-efficient and a
commercial success when we finished in
1999 we are extremely proud of what we
had achieved we installed pv seeds in
the building's curtain wall and four
hundred kilowatts worth of fuel cells we
designed the building with mechanical
space at the top and more efficient
heating and ventilation and air
conditioning systems a steel hat trust
and the additional weight of the
mechanical floor at the top of the
building acts as a counterweight and
allowed us to use significant
significantly less steel in the
construction we tripled the amount of
outside air vented into the building and
filtered out ninety percent of the
particular matter we created a template
to use as much local and recycled
material as possible and we insisted
that all construction debris be recycled
this was unheard of at the time and met
with much resistance but is now standard
practice and substantially reduces costs
we had truly made a better building and
a better building process and while we
had many successes we learned a lot from
our mistakes we spent a lot of time and
money on the pvcs and today they
generate about four hundred dollars a
year in electricity
they power the late boats the elevator
lobbies and mechanical floors life
expectancy was 20 years and the payback
was 25 the fuel cells require a
tremendous amount of maintenance greatly
depressing their economic viability and
in all likelihood we will be taking them
out within the next five years at the
time we thought we created a new and
superior template and no one would ever
build a conventional building again we
were wrong but we did establish the new
paradigm we take almost a decade for it
to be accepted in the mainstream this
time lag is partially due to the natural
apprehension the chat that change and
Enders but also to one of the central
challenges of sustainable development
every building is unique even relatively
minor differences in location use and
size can significantly alter the
building's design in operations thus
one-size-fits-all solutions for greening
buildings are inherently problematic
this is our issue with lead well the
industry did not immediately embrace
sustainable or green buildings the Durst
organization did 2003 we began the
planning of one Bryant Park we're now
guided by our experience of four times
square and the newly developed leed
standard for sustainable development we
learned that using the least amount of
energy and operating a building could
not and should not be the goal of
sustainable development we learned that
buildings are meant to be occupied and
enjoyed if the goal is only to reduce
energy consumption the building itself
will be inefficient unpleasant and
ultimately unravel using the least
amount of energy possible and operating
a building cannot be the goal of
sustainable construction we learn from
four times square that the goal of
sustainable development is efficiency a
green building is a building that uses
the earth's resources and energy
efficiently
and is an efficient and healthy place to
work well the fuel cells at four x
squared did not perform as we had hoped
we very much like the concept of
generating power on site and using dual
cycle energy generation to power our
buildings we designed into one Brian
Park a 4.6 megawatt combined heat and
power plant it runs on natural gas and
we use the waste heat to generate hot
water to heat the building and through
an absorption chiller to make air
conditioning power from a conventional
utility power plant it's about thirty
percent efficient while our coach and
plant approaches seventy percent
efficiency
I hope you don't ask me to run through
this and because the co gen plant needs
to run at one hundred percent capacity
24 24 hours seven days a week for
maximum efficiency we designed it to
work with a 40,000 ton ice storage
system it might the coach npower's an
electric chiller that instead of
producing chilled water to cool the
building chills 60 miles of plastic tube
that freezes 43 tanks of water into
frozen slush it's called a nice farm
because a frozen slush alarm just
doesn't sound so good either in the
morning instead of running a chiller we
use our ice batteries to cool the
building this allows our coach n plan to
operate continuously and negates the
need to run an 800 tons Hiller first
thing in the morning to cool the
building a few weeks out of the year the
building is able to run on the ice
storage system alone these are our ice
tanks the plant required a steep capital
investment close to 30 million dollars
but it performs brilliantly and if we
can hold off our local utilities attempt
standby charges to death it will quickly
pay for itself as an aside my daughter
hellena would like me to say that
methane can and should be easily
harvested from food waste in
agricultural weights to anaerobic
digestion we seriously investigated the
implementation of an anaerobic digester
in the basement of one Bryant Park to
deal with the food waste from the
cafeterias and restaurant in the
building unfortunately the amount of
food waste generated in the building
would never create enough methane to
justify the expense one Brian one Brian
parks water efficiency is one of our
proudest achievements though New York
has an abundant and cheap supply of
potable water but we believe this is a
temporary condition and as a
multi-generational real estate company
temporary is anything less than 20 years
while we are current where we currently
have a great fresh water delivery system
New York we have a lousy sewage
our combined sewers overrun our sewage
treatment pumping stations dozens of
times a year pumping billions of gallons
of raw sewage into New York's rivers and
harbors to combat this we installed a
number of water saving devices into one
Bryant Park we use waterless urinals in
the men's bathrooms a concept that was
vigorously opposed by the plumbing Union
despite that our water saving system
would add miles of plumbing to the
building we collect a majority of lorain
water that falls on our two acre site
New York gets about 4 feet of rain a
year we treat and reuse the building's
grain water gray water we collect the
ground water that flows into our 80 foot
deep cellar and also the water the
condenses from our steam cloud we then
use this water to flush one brian parks
toilets and for makeup water that has
lost through evaporation in the
building's cooling towers all told these
features save 13 million gallons this
slide was what we projected the savings
has been more substantial in order to
maximize the efficiency of the built out
space and to increase the productivity
of the workers at one Brian Park we
designed the building to be a healthy
and pleasant place to work our slab to
slab height at one Brian Park is 14 feet
7 inches this allowed us to install a
raised floor and have floor-to-ceiling
windows without the obstruction of a
convector well the glass has a ceramic
foot pattern baked into it to deflect
solar gain and is double paned and loi
it's still glass and glass is far from
the most efficient way to enclose a
building but daylight and visual access
to the outside world is more efficient
for the user than the value of the
decrease in energy efficiency a building
must work for its users and trapping
people eight hours a day in interior
offices and cubicles without access to
natural light does not work for the
inhabitants and does not allow them to
work
efficiently we have the same philosophy
when it comes to filtered outside air
when bryan park filters out ninety-five
percent of the particular matter and
provides two and a half times more
outside air than the code requires
tempering all that outside air and
filtering it increases the building's
energy use but once again we believe it
adds the efficiency and productivity of
the users we deliver this air through an
underfloor air system all the tenant
floors at one Brian Park sit atop a
14-inch pressured plenum and this plenum
space besides housing all the office
cables is how the tempered air is
distributed the office occupants the
system has a number of advantages it
uses less energy because we only temper
the air to 65 degrees as opposed to 55
in a standard overhead HVAC system it's
because the air it comes from the floor
does not have to cool and pass through
the warm air the top of the volume the
space makes this system makes
reconfiguring the layout of tennis space
much easier because there's not duct
work that needs to be rebuilt or
electric conduit to be moved when we
have to move a wall or change in office
from user perspective the system is
vastly superior the number one complaint
in offices is that someone is too hot
sitting right next to someone who is too
cold the Venson on the underfloor air
system are adjustable and each occupant
gets event this means that individuals
can control the temperature in their own
office or workspace the true test began
when we moved in to one Brian park and I
can say that we vastly understated the
advantage of working in this environment
over the over the last 50 years the
Durst organization has gotten in and out
of the residential business half a dozen
times currently we were back in today
with our partner Hal fattener we own
approximately 1,700 residential units
Manhattan with another 1200 in the
pipeline 2005 we opened the hellena
designed by FX file 600 unit LEED Gold
rental building the helaina was the
first voluntary lead residential
building in New York New York City and
the first New York building with an
affordable housing component to have a
glass curtain wall as opposed to masonry
usually brick exterior we built a number
of green features into the lena
including a black water system micro
turbines that supply hot water and
electricity and photovoltaic cells in
addition to sustainable technologies we
use concrete 425 with fly ash with waste
fly ash and the steel making process to
reduce the amount of cement required in
making concrete this was particularly
exciting for us because it reuses a
material that is normally thrown away as
well as reduces the amount of cement
needed to make concrete the helaina is
one of the first buildings to be built
with it when we built four times square
we were told it was too difficult and
too expensive to use fly ash and
concrete but at the helenia we insisted
and it ended up saving the contractor
money the use of fly ash concrete is now
standard in most construction and is
used in all our new buildings we even
won an award from the concrete industry
the micro turbines took so long to get
permitted that by the time we turned
them on they needed servicing
this is endemic challenge of sustainable
development to build a green building
you were building a better building and
trying technologies that are unproved
and untested sometimes this means that
the products and methods are more
expensive and time-consuming to install
and sometimes don't even work but more
often it means that there are no
regulatory schemes available to permit
these new technologies that is what
happened with our micro turbines we all
know that Michael Bloomberg is a
visionary when it comes to the
environment his plan NYC 2030 is a
blueprint for sustainable development of
new york city but even with great
leadership at the top introducing new
technologies into the building and fire
code is complex new york city loves
distributed generation but even though
we had a permit to install the micro
turbines no one told that to the fire
officer who showed up to permit our use
of the micro turbines to him it was a
hazard they wasn't familiar with and
would no way allow it to be turned on
calls replaced inquiries were made and
the fire department of New York pledged
to write rules and micro turbines this
took almost three years and so by the
time we did get it on it was already
broken a couple of years after finishing
the hellena we opened the epic at 125
West 31st Street also by FX foul a 400
unit rental building that shares space
with a friary for the Franciscan
brothers and an American Cancer Society
Hope Lodge the epic is LEED Gold and
while our other sustainable buildings
were filled with innovative technology
epic achieves lead quietly
cost-effectively by focusing on
materials and technologies that by the
top that by this time became easy to
source and use everyone asked about the
costs of building green which in my
opinion is a dumb question no one asks
how much more expensive it is to build a
building with elevators or air
conditioning the green features pay for
themselves
the real cost is the time it takes for
the planning effort and investigation
that must be done but in this effort
many of our building practices that were
considered green or a way to conserve
resources has become ingrained into the
work habits of our employees I'm
fortunate to work with great people who
truly care as much about the environment
as I do we now have a couple of very
exciting projects in the hopper next
year will break ground on our first
hotel project as you can see we don't
yet have a final design for the project
but we're working with cookplus Fox who
design one brian park and we expect it
to be an arresting design hopefully it
won't tip over to next door to the
hellena on West fifty-seventh Street
we've teamed up with a talented young
and very charming architect and my good
friend BRK ingles Bianca made my
acquaintance several years ago in
Denmark by asking me at a speech I was
giving in Copenhagen where my wife is
from why do all of your buildings look
like buildings it was a good question so
good that I made BRK answered himself
West fifty-seventh Street established as
a new typology for the Manhattan skyline
it combines brilliant architecture with
a functional design that maximizes light
views and air for the residents the
central courtyard is borrowed from a
typical residential block in Copenhagen
and will be a unique amenity for the
residents the courtyard nearly half the
size of a football field would be a
green space with views of the Hudson
River Manhattan south of 57th Street and
filled with areas for active and passive
recreation both of these buildings will
be sustainable we were not yet sure if
they will be lead lead is a great
standard and has brought the sustainable
building movement a long way
short time but lead is a standard my
family and company has always had
problems with standards and authority we
are steadfastly committed to sustainable
construction and operations of our
portfolio but are contemplating creating
our own process they'll be more
conducive to our innovative nature for
nearly a century we have chartered our
own course from New York City real
estate we have built in place as others
swore off expanded when others
retrenched and build green before we
even knew what it meant like building a
sustainable building there is no end
goal for my family's company it's all a
process of building building better and
more efficient buildings and leaving
this world a little bit better than how
he found it thank
I driver
I think everyone enjoyed not only the
part about what you've done but the
whole story of your family after that a
personal approach to development of true
business is something we don't care very
much about and I think we really
appreciate it hearing about it I
certainly did I think we probably have a
few questions and I know you'll be
willing to answer them so I will ask for
questions from the audience we put the
lights up a bit Carter Wiseman has a
question your organization seems
extraordinarily innovative and
aggressive a couple of times you
mentioned running into regulatory
problems I'm curious whether the in this
case the New York City regulatory
agencies are as innovative and as
receptive to your innovations as you
would like them to be and whether you
can help them be more so the answer is
excuse me they certainly are not as
receptive when we proposed our water
saving methods measures at one Brian
part the New York City Dec was against
it because they would be losing revenue
we then explained to them the importance
of reducing the water flowing into the
sewage system and now they are actually
offering rebates to people who do to
order saving technologies they we always
hit resistance but after a while the
we're able to convince people that this
is the right way to proceed there's some
more as a question way over there we
need to get a mind kids coming
thank you you talked about increasing
the productivity of the workers how do
you measure that productivity and is
increased productivity always a good
thing joey is not American
when when we were renting one Bryant
Park we met with two different two
different investment companies
investment bankers the first one we told
them how much more productive everybody
would be working in a building with the
fresh with the additional outside air
and light and they told this didn't
matter they couldn't make they could be
any more productive they couldn't make
any more any more money than they did so
the second one told us that this was the
only building his wife would allow him
to leave space in the productivity is
usually measured by sick days and
absences and studies have shown that
this type of building can reduce by that
measure increased productivity by
between ten and fifteen percent and I
think just for everybody's health it's
an important factor if if for no other
reason question what right there right
yes it seems like the building's you've
shown us are all on the island of
Manhattan I wondered if you've
considered exporting your expertise
abroad for example to New Jersey or even
Brooklyn we have looked at going outside
New York my father was known for saying
that he would not buy a building he
couldn't walk to and I've always said
thank goodness he was lived in midtown
Manhattan but we have tried we have
looked at other places we we actually
once tried to do something in Portland
Oregon but discovered that real estate
is local we can go across the river we
are doing a project in northern Dutchess
County but so far we've only been found
things to do in New York in Manhattan
excuse me
questions no bets comic wait a minute
you mentioned on the four times square
project when you described a sort of
typical dynamic between architects and
contractors and the sort of a blame game
that goes on you said you developed a
different model for finding solutions as
opposed to assigning blame this is a
topic of some conversation here at the
school these days and like to hear a
little bit more detail about what that
model isn't how it works it starts with
having these off-site retreats so that
it's not within the work environment and
where people can relate to each other as
people rather than as architects or
engineers and we then we then try and
get everybody to agree as to what the
goals of the project are and in
particular to agree that we're not
looking to find blame we're only looking
for solutions and we're looking to build
as I said what the best building that we
can a building that we're all going to
be very proud of and we've been very
successful in doing that you we develop
a great sense of teamwork and everybody
has bought into the project but it it
really requires a lot of effort it's not
not easy for sociology or is it manifest
in say contract structures compensation
methods risk management more it's why
it's not it's not a anything that we do
contract with a contractor or how people
get paid but it's we make sure that
everybody involved in the project has
the same same goal of building the
building completed and sometimes people
will talk one way and act another and
then they're not involved in the next
project
Kevin wrote I don't really have a
question I just want to say how very
important your message is to this young
audience of architects it's very
important that they finally focus on
these issues you know architectural
education tends to be more focused on
design on identity or exotic buildings
but this is really the critical stuff
that we all must understand that we all
must apply as we go into the future so
thank you very much well thank you mr.
other questions after that or shall we
shall we retire on mr. roaches kind
words of appreciation and thank him for
those and thank terrestres